au delà de l'étiquette partisane la
dimension personnelle le vote n'est fait
surtout dans les départements le scrutin
majoritaire mais également dans les
départements où il ya de la
proportionnelle le vote est un mélange
toujours cercle de choix politiques
d'orientation politique mais est la
dimension personnelle est extrêmement
fort c'est une excellent particulière
parce que dans de multiples départements
c'est la seule élection où les électeurs
connaissent les élus y connaissent les
candidats ils les rencontres se sont
parfois ils ont presque des liens
d'amitié avec une différente avec les
élections législatives
bien sûr ça ne m'a rien à voir nous
qu'on ouvre ton petit citoyens que nous
sommes en effet nous ne connaissons pas
les candidats se rapprochent de
municipal finalement ça sera quand je
t'ai municipal dans l'année du lit
troisième tour des municipales dans les
petites communes uniquement parce que
imaginer quelqu'un dans une grande
commune que ce soit paris lyon ou
marseille qui vote il ne connaît pas les
candidats mais en revanche en effet ce
lien
entre les lecteurs et l'élu qui est très
fort dans les petites communes on le
retrouve dans les départements qui dans
lesquels on a voté dans les résultats
que le couple que l'on vient de
détailler avec pierre ory ou avec un
traduit vous nous retrouver tous bien
sûr on le voit très bien on le voit très
bien puisque toutes ces élections
locales étaient des élections
défavorables à la gauche et vous
regardez dans les pyrénées dans les
pyrénées atlantiques où madame espagnac
aurait pu vraiment être battus en
fonction du rapport de force politique
eh bien elle arrive à tenir la tête hors
de l'eau on voit bien que c'est
certainement dû comment dire à la
surface personnelle de madame espagnac
dans ce département en revanche son
collègue lui est battu